Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. And if I sound unusually jolly this morning, it is because today is the last of our 12 or 13 days of Christmas marathon. A marathon that Tom Holland was entirely your idea. I'm delighted that we did it. Yeah, I was right. But I'm even more delighted
感谢收听《历史Remainder》节目。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史Remainder》。如果我今天早上听起来格外高兴，那是因为今天是我们的12天或13天圣诞马拉松的最后一天。汤姆·霍兰德，这个马拉松完全是你的主意。我很高兴我们做到了。对，我是对的。但我更高兴的是
that we are now approaching the finish line. But what a brilliant pair of anniversaries we have to mark this day. So it's 6th of January. And we've been having quite a few downers, haven't we, recently? It's been very grim. The Dreyfus case, lots of death,
我们现在终于要冲过终点线了。不过，我们今天要纪念的这一对周年纪念日真是太棒了。今天是1月6日。我们最近经历了不少让人沮丧的事，对吧？气氛非常严峻。德雷福斯案，大量的死亡，
Albert Camus dying. Slavery. Slavery. Slavery, yeah. Great stuff. But today is, well, it's not a great day, but the upshot of it is splendid. Excellent. That is the ambushing of Alfred the Great at Chippenham by the Vikings in 878. And it's probably today.
阿尔贝·加缪的去世。奴隶制。奴隶制。没错，奴隶制。太棒了。但今天——好吧，虽然不是什么好日子，但结果却十分精彩。太棒了。那就是公元878年维京人在奇彭纳姆伏击了阿尔弗雷德大帝。这大概就发生在今天。
The Anglo-Saxon Chronicle says that it took place in midwinter after Twelfth Night. So probably today, 6th of January. And he was obviously, he'd probably been celebrating Christmas in Great Hall in Chippenham in Wessex. And the Vikings, like the treacherous dogs that they are, launch an ambush on him. So the backdrop to this, Dominic,
《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》记载，此事发生于仲冬主显节之后。所以很可能就是今天，即1月6日。他当时显然一直在威塞克斯奇彭纳姆的大厅里庆祝圣诞节。而维京人就像他们那群背信弃义的恶狗一样，向他发起了伏击。多米尼克，这一切的背景，
it's a thrilling one, is it not? I don't know. You're going to tell me. Of course you do. You know this. I remember this from The Last Kingdom, no doubt. And from the Lady Bird book. Oh, yeah.
真是惊心动魄，不是吗？我不知道。你来告诉我。你当然知道。你知道这个。毫无疑问，你对《最后王国》和《瓢虫书》里都有印象。哦，对。
There's a fabulous illustration in the Lady Bird book. They've been celebrating Christmas, haven't they? Yeah. So take us through this. So the backdrop to this is the invasion of the Great Heathen Army, this terrifying Viking invasion force that lands in 865 and basically just goes around kind of smashing up Anglo-Saxon kingdoms. Is this Guthrum?
《瓢虫书》里有一幅绝妙的插图。他们之前一直在庆祝圣诞节，对吧？是的。那你来给我们讲讲吧。所以，这一切的背景就是伟大异教徒军队的入侵，这是一支可怕的维京入侵部队，于865年登陆，基本上就是到处摧毁盎格鲁-撒克逊人的王国。这是古思伦吗？
Yeah, it's Guthrum. guthrum guthrum is this that fellow in uh poor japanese anglia who ends up being um shot with arrows say edmund so first of all northumbria gets uh toppled um and then um yes edmund the king of the east angles gets captured and shot with arrows uh gets beheaded um and his head gets guarded by a wolf and a peasant is going through the wood and the wolf says hick hick hick latin of course for yeah here here here and the peasant goes over and there is the head i love a latin speaking a joke and in um the very st edmunds is a wonderful statue of the wolf of the wolf not of edmund yeah there's a statue of edmund as well but okay statue of the wolf anyway so um so that happens and that's not good and that leaves mercia the kingdom of the
对，是古思伦。古思伦、古思伦。就是东盎格利亚的那家伙，后来被乱箭射死……等等，是埃德蒙。所以首先，诺森比亚被推翻了；然后，是的，东盎格利亚国王埃德蒙被俘，被乱箭射死，被斩首，他的头颅由一头狼守护着。一个农民走进树林，狼说“hick hick hick”——当然，这是拉丁语，意思是“这里、这里、这里”——然后农民走过去，头颅就在那里。我太喜欢拉丁语笑话了。在圣埃德蒙兹，有一尊非常棒的狼的雕像——是狼的雕像，不是埃德蒙的雕像。是的，也有埃德蒙的雕像，但总之……好吧，狼的雕像。总之，事情就是这样，这可不是什么好事，这使得麦西亚王国——
midlands and wessex the south um and uh alfred is the is the youngest of five brothers had never expected to become king, but it's a really bad time to be a king of Wessex at the moment. So 871, Alfred becomes king and absolutely, you know, the eye of the storm. He has a good track record as a warrior. He's, you know, a seasoned Viking fighter, but his reign gets off to a terrible start when he gets beaten up at Wilton,
中部地区，以及南方的威塞克斯……阿尔弗雷德是五个兄弟中最小的一个，从未想过自己会成为国王，但现在绝对是当威塞克斯国王最糟糕的时期。所以在871年，阿尔弗雷德成为国王，正处于暴风眼中心。他有着很好的战士履历，是个经验丰富的维京战士，但他的统治却以一个糟糕的开端拉开序幕——他在威尔顿被打败了，
the town closest to which I grew up. Yeah, Wilton is very, this is very much a personal mistake of this, yes. So he gets defeated in his, the very first engagement as king and he has to buy the Vikings off. The Vikings withdraw to London, then to Torxie in Lincolnshire
也就是我长大的那个小镇附近。是的，威尔顿……这绝对是阿尔弗雷德个人的失误。所以他在作为国王的第一场战役中就战败了，他不得不花钱收买维京人。维京人撤退到伦敦，然后又撤到了林肯郡的托克西，
because there's been a revolt in Northumbria against them. A puppet king, they get rid of him. That's the end of the Anglo-Saxon monarchy in Northumbria. Then 873, the Vikings decide it's time to move in on Mercia. And the king of Mercia is a guy called
因为诺森比亚发生了一场针对他们的叛乱。他们废黜了一个傀儡国王。诺森比亚的盎格鲁-撒克逊君主制就这样结束了。接着在873年，维京人决定对麦西亚发起进攻。麦西亚的国王是一个叫
Burgred, who is closely... You know, the Mercians and West Saxons have had an uneasy relationship. But in the face of this Viking threat, they've become quite close allies. Burgred has married Alfred's elder sister, Athelswith, actually in Chippenham. So Chippenham is, you know, this wedding was a kind of marker of West Saxon Mercian friendship. The Vikings in 873 move in. They occupy Repton, which is the great kind of burial place for the Mercian kings. And that essentially symbolizes the fall of Mercia.
勃尔格雷德的人，他和……你知道，麦西亚人和西撒克逊人过去的关系一直不太融洽。但在维京人的威胁面前，他们成了相当亲密的盟友。勃尔格雷德实际上是在奇彭纳姆娶了阿尔弗雷德的姐姐埃瑟尔斯思。所以奇彭纳姆，这场婚礼可以说是西撒克逊与麦西亚友谊的标志。873年，维京人发起进攻。他们占领了雷普顿，那是麦西亚国王们宏大的埋葬地。这基本上象征着麦西亚的沦陷。
Burgred and Athelswith flee abroad. The Vikings are left in complete control of Mercia. They adopt a, well, the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle describes him as a foolish thane. Foolish thane? A foolish thane, a man called Caolwulf. And so there's been some debate recently as to whether this guy Caolwulf really was a foolish thane. Perhaps he was, you know, revisionist takes because coins have been found in which he and Alfred are shown as paired kings. But I think he clearly, I mean, I think, you know, this is a Viking puppet on the throne.
勃尔格雷德和埃瑟尔斯思逃往海外。维京人完全控制了麦西亚。他们扶植了一个——盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史将他描述为一个愚蠢的塞尔恩（领主）。愚蠢的塞尔恩？一个愚蠢的塞尔恩，一个名叫切尔武尔夫的人。因此，最近有人争论这个叫切尔武尔夫的家伙是否真的是一个愚蠢的塞尔恩。也许是的，这是修正主义的观点，因为人们发现了铸有他和阿尔弗雷德双人头像的硬币。但我认为他显然——我的意思是，我认为，这不过是王位上的一个维京傀儡。
That probably was a foolish thing to do. So basically, East Anglia and Northumbria by this point have been completely decapitated. Mercia, there is this foolish thing on the throne. Alfred is, you know, Alfred's Wessex is the last kingdom completely decapitated mercia there is this foolish thing on the throne alfred is really you know alfred's wessex is the last kingdom in the formulation of burner cornwall and the attacks keep coming so 875 they move in on wareham in dorset uh then exeter um probably the only thing that saves wessex at this point is that when the Viking fleet are
这样做确实很蠢。所以基本上，东盎格利亚和诺森比亚到这个时候已经被彻底斩首了。麦西亚王位上则坐着这个愚蠢的塞尔恩。阿尔弗雷德的威塞克斯——用伯纳·康威尔的话说，阿尔弗雷德的威塞克斯是最后一个王国。麦西亚被彻底斩首，王位上坐着这个愚蠢的塞尔恩，阿尔弗雷德的威塞克斯真的是——用伯纳·康威尔的话说，阿尔弗雷德的威塞克斯是最后一个王国。而且攻击还在继续：875年，他们进攻多塞特的韦勒姆，然后是埃克塞特。此时此刻，唯一拯救威塞克斯的可能就是，当维京舰队
leaving Wareham for Exeter, there's a great storm and they all get wiped out. So that's, you know, a few for that. But 877, again, a great invasion. Alfred draws up terms, they swap hostages, the Vikings withdraw from Wessex. And Alfred is sufficiently trusting of this treaty that this I think is what enables him to feel that he can celebrate the festive season because Christmas is not just Christmas Day it is the 12 days that follow Christmas as well that's all part of the
从韦勒姆离开前往埃克塞特时，遭遇了一场大风暴，他们全军覆没。所以，这算是一点小小的……但到了877年，又是一次大规模入侵。阿尔弗雷德拟定了条款，双方交换人质，维京人从威塞克斯撤军。阿尔弗雷德对这份条约相当信任，我认为正是这一点让他觉得自可以安心庆祝节日，因为圣诞节不仅仅是圣诞节当天，还包括之后的12天，这些都是
the season and so the Vikings know this they're treacherous and so that's why they launch their ambush. And Alfred is caught absolutely sitting. And this is one of the, I mean,
节日的一部分。因此，维京人很清楚这一点，他们背信弃义，所以才发起了伏击。阿尔弗雷德就这样被杀了个措手不及。这真是——我的意思是，
this is a, this is a kind of a seismic moment because if, if Alfred had been killed, we probably wouldn't be doing this podcast. Humanity would have descended into the abyss, Tom. That's a big claim. So Alfred's life is the thread by which the survival of an independent Anglo-Saxon kingdom survive.
这是一个具有震撼性的时刻，因为如果阿尔弗雷德被杀，我们大概就不会在这里做这个播客了。人类将坠入深渊，汤姆。这话说得有点大。所以阿尔弗雷德的生命就是独立盎格鲁-撒克逊王国得以存续的唯一命脉。
Yeah. If Alfred had died, if Alfred had been killed, the Vikings would have taken over Wessex. I mean, it's not to say that Anglo-Saxon civilization would have been over Wessex. I mean it's not to say that Anglo-Saxon civilisation would have been completely extinguished but it's likely that the English speaking kingdom
对。如果阿尔弗雷德死了，如果阿尔弗雷德被杀，维京人就会接管威塞克斯。这并不是说盎格鲁-撒克逊文明在威塞克斯会彻底湮灭，但由阿尔弗雷德的努力而最终崛起的使用英语的英格兰王国
of England that emerges chiefly thanks to Alfred's efforts would probably not have emerged. So in the long run we'd be a kind of Franco-Danish society do you think? I suppose it kind of Franco-Danish society, do you think? I suppose it would be Anglo-Danish, wouldn't it?
可能就不会诞生了。所以从长远来看，你认为我们会变成一个类似法兰德斯的社会吗？我想，这类似于法兰德斯社会，你觉得呢？我想那会是盎格鲁-丹麦社会吧，对不对？
I mean, but you could imagine. Well, the French would have come eventually. But the influence of the Kingdom of England on British history, on European history, and on world history is so profound. You think there'd be, I mean, you seem to imply that you didn't believe there would be podcasts if Alfred had been captured. Well, but we're doing
我的意思是，你可以想象一下。嗯，法国人最终还是会来的。但英格兰王国对英国历史、欧洲历史以及世界历史的影响是如此深远。你觉得——我的意思是，你似乎暗示如果没有阿尔弗雷德被俘，就不会有现在的播客。嗯，我们是用英语做
this podcast in English. We would, I think, you know, and the reason that we can do this podcast and be listened to people in America, in Australia, you know, in non-English speaking countries where English is the lingua franca owes a huge
这个播客的。我们之所以能做这个播客，并且能被美国、澳大利亚以及那些英语作为通用语的非英语国家的听众听到，很大程度上要
amount to the fact that... So there's some parallel universe in which we're doing this, in which we are massive in Scandinavia. Yes, exactly. Right? Well, we're speaking in some Anglo-Scandinavian dialect. And the only people who are listening to us are people maybe in Mercia and Wessex.
归功于……所以存在这样一个平行宇宙，我们在那里用英语做播客，而在那个宇宙里我们在斯堪的纳维亚超级火。对，没错。对吧？我们说着某种盎格鲁-斯堪的纳维亚方言。唯一听我们节目的人可能是在麦西亚和威塞克斯。
No, but I we when we go to our live tours in in uh norway great crowds greet us at the airports all right and the anglo-danish realm of newfoundland right uh norse brethren they're famous i can't do a danish i can't do a danish accented t the rest is i'm not even gonna try it i'm not gonna try it but i i mean who knows what but but i do think that that world history might have been significantly different because without the emergence of england is it are we about to get to the the the great moments in alfred's life are they about yes so alfred does escape uh he takes refuge on the isle of Athelney, which is in the Somerset levels and is literally an island because at that point it's surrounded by marshes and swamps.
不，当我们去挪威进行现场巡演时，机场会有大批粉丝热烈欢迎我们，对吧？还有纽芬兰的盎格鲁-丹麦王国，对吧？——那些诺斯兄弟，他们很有名。我模仿不来丹麦口音……《历史Remainder》——我甚至都不打算试了，我才不试呢。不过——谁知道呢，但我确实认为世界历史可能会有很大不同，因为如果没有英格兰的崛起……我们是不是快要讲到阿尔弗雷德生平中的高光时刻了？是要讲了吗？是的，所以阿尔弗雷德逃脱了，他逃到了萨默塞特湿地的阿瑟尼岛避难，那里真的是一座岛屿，因为当时它四面环水，全都是沼泽和湿地。
And so he's basically secure there. It's famous for the story of the burning of the cakes. Yeah. And also people who've listened to our episode on St. Cuthbert may remember that St. Cuthbert turns up as well and supplies him with lots of fish. Yes. So that enables Alfred to hold out. He sends out messengers across Wessex to meet him at a place called Egbert's Stone on the border between Somerset and Wiltshire. He then leads them and they meet
所以在那里他基本上是安全的。这里有关于烧焦蛋糕的故事，非常有名。是的。另外，听过我们关于圣卡斯伯特那一集的听众可能还记得，圣卡斯伯特也出现了，并为他提供了大量的鱼。是的。这使得阿尔弗雷德能够坚持下去。他派出信使走遍威塞克斯，让他们在萨默塞特和威尔特郡边界一个叫埃格伯特之石的地方集合。然后他率领他们，与维京军队在
with the Viking army at a place called Eddington. And it's a thumping victory. And the measure of how thumping it is, is that the Vikings run away. They, Alfred besieges them in their camp, presumably at Chippenham. And after two weeks, the Vikings have to surrender.
一个叫埃丁顿的地方交战。这是一场压倒性的胜利。这场胜利有多彻底呢？那就是维京人被打得落荒而逃。阿尔弗雷德把他们围困在军营里，估计就是在奇彭纳姆。两周后，维京人不得不投降。
And for the first time, it's the Vikings who have to hand over hostages. It's not a mutual swap of hostages. And they're forced to convert to christianity and guthrum takes on the name of athelstan he does not the athelstan not the champion not the champion but it shows that the name is kind of in the ether yeah alfred stands as his godfather and by terms of this treaty uh alfred gets london and he has recognized that london is the kind of the key to controlling the south uh so he moves in he fortifies it um you can still see the the outlines
这是破天荒第一次，轮到维京人交出人质了，这不再是双方互换人质。他们被迫改信基督教，并且古思伦取了个教名叫埃塞尔斯坦——不是那个埃塞尔斯坦，不是那个冠军，不是那个冠军，但这表明这个名字当时在空中飘荡。是的。阿尔弗雷德作为他的教父出席，根据这项条约的条款，阿尔弗雷德得到了伦敦，他意识到伦敦是控制南方的关键所在，所以他入驻伦敦并将其加固。你至今仍然可以看到
of the dock it's the only part of the the lineaments of the anglo-saxon city that still survives um and in due course a further treaty is agreed whereby Mercia, basically, it's kind of like France after in 1940 gets divided in two. And you have this line running from the Mersey down to the Thames Estuary. And on the west side of that, Alfred basically takes over. Although, as we talked in the Athelstan episode, he's careful not to brand it as a West Saxon takeover. His daughter Athelflad marries the leading elder man of, the leading Earl of Mercia, Athelred and first Lord of the Mercians,
码头的轮廓，那是盎格鲁-撒克逊城市遗迹中唯一存留的部分。不久之后，双方达成了一项进一步的条约，麦西亚基本上——有点像1940年之后的法国那样——被一分为二。从默西河一直延伸到泰晤士河口有一条分界线。在这条线的西侧，基本上由阿尔弗雷德接管。尽管正如我们在埃塞尔斯坦那一集里所谈到的那样，他刻意不把它打上西撒克逊接管的烙印。他的女儿埃瑟尔弗莱德嫁给了麦西亚的主要长老、麦西亚的主要伯爵埃塞尔雷德——麦西亚的第一男爵，
first lady of the Mercians and the Vikings take the other side. And Alfred's determination to secure Wessex is what provides the launch pad for his son, Edward, and his daughter, Athelflaed, in the great year of 917 to launch the conquest of East Anglia and the Viking half of Mercia. You're almost 50 years away now from your original date. I know, I know. But I'm just saying that this is, you know this is a we have we have the moment of darkness and then everything it's a good it's a great story and i know i'm a stuck record on this but the uh the depiction of the the the sort of setback the comeback and the triumphant victory at eddington or wherever it is in the bernard cornwell tv series the Kingdom, is splendid. I can't recommend it too highly. Have you seen that, Tom?
麦西亚的第一女爵，而维京人则占据了另一侧。阿尔弗雷德确保威塞克斯安全的坚定决心，为他的儿子爱德华和女儿埃瑟尔弗莱德在公元917年那个伟大的年份发起对东盎格利亚和麦西亚维京控制区的征服奠定了基础。你现在距离你最初的时间点已经快过去50年了。我知道，我知道。但我的意思是，这是——你知道，这是一个充满黑暗的时刻，然后一切都转危为安。这是一个伟大的故事，我知道我在老调重弹，但在伯纳·康威尔的电视剧《最后的王国》中，对威塞克斯遇挫、卷土重来以及在埃丁顿（无论具体在哪）取得辉煌胜利的描绘，简直棒极了。我怎么推荐都不为过。汤姆，你看过那个吗？
Yeah, I have. It's good, isn't it? It's very good. Alfred goes up to the top of the hill. He doesn't know whether anyone's going to join him. And then he hears the hoofbeats in the distance. And England has risen. Oh, it's a great moment, Tom.
看过，我看了。很不错，对吧？非常棒。阿尔弗雷德走到山顶，他不知道是否会有人加入他。然后他听到了远处传来的马蹄声，英格兰觉醒了。哦，那真是个伟大的时刻，汤姆。
But it's filmed in the Czech Republic, I think. Yeah, but it doesn't matter. No, it did matter because it wasn't Wiltshire. If they filmed it in England, that would have been the car park of an Asda. But it didn't look anything like Wiltshire. Well, it looked more like Wiltshire. Surely it looked more like Wiltshire then than
但我想那是在捷克共和国拍摄的。是的，但这没关系。不，这有关系，因为那里不是威尔特郡。如果他们在英格兰拍摄，那背景就会是阿斯达超市的停车场了。但它看起来一点也不像威尔特郡。嗯，它看起来更像威尔特郡。难道它不比
Wiltshire now does. Maybe it should look like Wiltshire now. It shouldn't look like Wiltshire. I mean, Wiltshire now is like, in my experience, the A303. Isn't it? Isn't that Wiltshire? No nonsense. No. Right. Let us reconvene after the break with Samuel Pepys, my favourite diarist.
现在的威尔特郡更像过去的威尔特郡吗？也许它应该看起来像现在的威尔特郡吧。它才不该像威尔特郡呢。我的意思是，根据我的经验，现在的威尔特郡就像是A303公路。难道不是吗？难道那不是威尔特郡吗？胡说八道。没有。好吧，我们休息一会儿，回来后讲讲我最喜欢的日记作家塞缪尔·皮佩斯。
Well, him and Tony Benn. We will reconvene with Pepys after the break. See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A,
嗯，还有托尼·本。我们休息一会儿，回来后接着讲皮佩斯。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐Remainder》节目。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点八卦猛料，还有我们的问答环节，
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to the very last segment of our 12 Days of Christmas special. We're on the 6th of January.
我们将为你揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告音频、加更节目以及抢先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好，欢迎回到我们12天圣诞特别节目的最后一部分。今天是1月6日。
Alfred the Great has just been sent running into the marshes of Athelni. And Dominic, now your choice. And we are in 1661. Monday, the 7es of Athelney. And Dominic, now your choice. And we are in 1661. Monday, the 7th of January. This morning, news was brought to me to my bedside that there had been a great... The 7th of January? Yes. Yes.
阿尔弗雷德大帝刚刚被迫逃入阿瑟尼的沼泽。多米尼克，现在轮到你选了。我们来到了1661年。1月7日，星期一。今天早上，有人到床前向我报告说，发生了一件大事……1月7日？是的。是的。
Have ye of little faith. You think I'd have got the wrong date. Okay. All right. Yeah, go on. Monday, the 7th of January. This morning, news was brought to me to my bedside that there had been... Ah.
你这个小信徒。你以为我会记错日期。好吧。好吧。行，你接着说。1月7日，星期一。今天早上，有人到床前向我报告说，发生了一场……啊。
How could I have doubted you? News was brought to me to my bedside... The blue perfect case kicking in. ...that there had been a great stir in the city this night by the fanatics, who had been up and killed six or seven men, but all have fled. My lord mayor and the whole city had been in arms above 40,000. To the office, and after that to dinner, when my brother Tom came and dined with me,
我怎么会怀疑你呢？有人来到我的床前向我报告说……偏执狂发作了……昨晚城里由于狂热分子引发了一场大骚乱，他们暴动并杀死了六七个人，但现在全都逃跑了。市长大人和全城武装人员出动了4万多人。我去了办公室，之后去吃晚饭，我的弟弟汤姆来和我一起吃晚饭。
and after dinner, leaving twelve pence for the servants to buy cake with at night, this day being kept as twelfth day. Then Samuel Pepys, this is Samuel Pepys' diary. He goes up to the theatre, and he says, And in our way home we were in many places strictly examined, more than in the worst of times, there being great fears of these fanatics rising again. For the present, I do not hear that any of them are taken.
晚饭后，留下十二便士给仆人们晚上买蛋糕吃，因为今天是主显节。接着塞缪尔·皮佩斯——这是塞缪尔·皮佩斯的日记。他去了剧院，他在日记里写道：在回家的路上，我们在许多地方遭到严格盘问，比局势最恶劣的时候还要严，因为人们非常担心这些狂热分子再次暴动。目前，我没有听说他们之中有任何人被抓获。
So what's happened, Tom, is that the previous day, the 6th of January, the fanatics have risen in London to try to start an uprising uprising do you want to know what happens to them how it ends i'll tell you who the fanatics are in a second so thursday so this that's thursday the 8th 9th uh 10th uh peeps meets his friend mr davis who's a civil servant mr davis says the fanatics have been, they routed all the trained bands they met with. They put the King's lifeguards to the run.
所以发生了什么事呢，汤姆？就是在前一天，即1月6日，狂热分子在伦敦发动暴动，试图挑起一场起义……起义？你想知道他们结局如何吗？他们是怎么结束的？我一会儿就告诉你这些狂热分子是谁。所以，星期四——这是星期四，1月8日、9日、10日……皮佩斯遇到了他的朋友戴维斯先生，他是一名公务员。戴维斯先生说，狂热分子一路势不可挡，击溃了他们遇到所有训练有素的民兵连。他们把国王的近卫军逼得落荒而逃。
They killed about 20 men. They broke through the city gates twice. And all this in the daytime when all the city was in arms. And do you know how many of them were? There were only 31 of them. And Mr. Davis says, we did believe that there were at least 500 of them because they were charging around the place, but there weren't many. Well, that's nothing for you, isn't it?
他们杀死了大约20人。他们两次冲破了城门。而这一切都发生在光天化日之下，当时全城都在戒严。你知道他们有多少人吗？他们只有31个人。戴维斯先生说，我们本以为他们至少有500人，因为他们在各个地方横冲直撞，但实际上人并不多。这简直不可思议，对吧？
A thing that never was heard of, that so few men should dare and do so much mischief. Their word was, so their sort of motto was, the King Jesus and the heads upon the gates. Few of them would receive any quarter, but such as were taken by force and kept alive, expecting Jesus to come here and reign in the world presently and will not believe yet but their work will be carried on though they do die so who are these fanatics who've been rampaging through london well they are the fifth monarchists or the fifth monarchy men so they're a kind of extreme puritan kind of sect who have, um, they've got, they've got, um, they've got going in the sort of 1650s after the assassin, after the assassination, after the execution of them,
前所未闻，如此少的人竟然敢于并且制造了这么大的混乱。他们的口号——也就是他们的座右铭是：“国王耶稣和城门上的首级”。他们几乎不接受任何投降，除非是被武力俘虏并被留下活口的人，他们期望耶稣会立刻来到世上并在此称王，至今仍坚信即使他们死去，他们的大业也会继续进行。那么，这些在伦敦横行霸道的狂热分子究竟是谁呢？他们是第五王权派或第五王权信徒。他们是一群极端清教徒式的派别，
I believe he would, he would say master after the execution of, uh, Charles the first, and they've got very carried away because they think that the end times are near and they have been, they've been perhaps over reading the book of daniel um yes which which as you will know tom i says that there were going to be four great monarchies four beasts come out of the ocean right and they're the four beast it's the
嗯……他们在16世纪50年代兴起，在刺杀……在处决了——我相信他会称其为主谋——在处决了查理一世之后，他们变得极其狂热，因为他们认为末日即将来临，他们可能对《但以理书》进行了过度解读。
greatest of the lot the fourth beast is rome isn't it well um during the judean revolt um yes they people the judeans think that rome is the fourth beast but um then during the seventh century they think it's the arabs all right i didn't know they thought it was basically they keep having to change it yeah according to which is the superpower so anyway the book of daniel people basically have got their this idea that there are four great monarchies one is babylonian one is Persia, one is Macedonian, Alexander, and the other one is Roman or Arab or whoever. And then the fifth monarchy will be the kingdom of Christ. Yeah, Jesus.
是的，正如汤姆你所知的那样，《但以理书》里说将会有四个伟大的帝国，四只野兽从海中升起，对吧？它们就是那四只野兽……其中最厉害的是第四只野兽，罗马，对吗？嗯……在犹太人起义期间，是的，犹太人认为罗马就是第四只野兽；但是，嗯，到了公元7世纪，人们又认为那是阿拉伯人。好吧，我不知道他们还这么认为。总之，他们必须不断改变看法，根据谁是当时的超级大国而定。所以无论如何，《但以理书》的信徒们基本上坚信这样一种观念：有四个伟大的帝国：一个是巴比伦帝国，一个是波斯帝国，一个是马其顿帝国（亚历山大大帝），另一个是罗马帝国、阿拉伯帝国或其他什么帝国。然后第五个帝国将是基督的王国。对，耶稣。
No king but Jesus. And this becomes very popular in the 1650s with some people in the New Model Army. The chief guy's a are called General Harrison, General Thomas Harrison, but he's executed after Charles II is restored. Isn't that the one that peeps? He watches his execution.
普天之下唯有耶稣为王。这在16世纪50年代的新模范军中变得非常流行。领头的人是一个叫哈里森将军的人，即托马斯·哈里森将军，但他在查理二世复辟后被处决了。那不是皮佩斯去观看处决的人吗？
That's right. I think he looked as cheerful as any man could do in that condition. Yeah. Very impressive. So the leadership. That's a chariot cross, I think. Is it?
没错。我觉得他表现得像那种情况下任何一个人所能做到的一样乐观。是的。非常令人印象深刻。所以领导层……那是查理十字街，对吧？是吗？
Yeah, I think so. I think it's on the spot where um where the statue of charles i is now but is that so we should have talked about this in our statues yeah so the leadership then passes to a man called thomas venner thomas venner is a cooper so he's a barrel maker and he has spent 20 years in america New England, and he's returned fired up. He's full of all mad American ideas. Exactly.
对，我想是的。我想它就在现在查理一世雕塑所在的地方……我们本该在我们的雕塑那一集里聊聊这个的。所以领导层后来传给了一个叫托马斯·维纳的人。托马斯·维纳是个库珀，也就是个制桶匠，他在美洲新英格兰生活了20年，归来时满腔热血，充满各种疯狂的美洲思想。没错。
He's Meghan Markle. He's come to England with all his fancy American ideas. Causing the end of chaos. And he has just become the leader of the fifth monarchy men. And they are absolutely certain, you know, Jesus is coming. It could be hours away hours away um they're very down on um charles ii yeah they their main a lot of them are sort of new model army
他简直就是梅根·马克尔。他带着所有花哨的美洲思想来到英格兰，引发了一场混乱。他刚刚成为了第五王权派的领袖。他们绝对确信——你知道的，耶稣就要来了，可能就在几个小时之内……他们非常看不起查理二世。是的，他们的主力军大多是新模范军的老兵，他们曾为伟大正义的事业而战，现在他们认为这一切都付诸东流了。他们在科尔曼街附近天鹅巷的一家酒馆里碰头——我不知道那在哪里，但你凭借你所有的散步经验可能知道，总之大概在伦敦城内的某个地方。基本上发生的事情是，他们决定发动一场起义。非常愚蠢。他们只有大约50人。他们首先前往圣保罗大教堂，去找一个叫约翰逊先生的人开的书店。他手里有圣保罗大教堂的钥匙，他们管他要钥匙。
veterans they fought for the good old cause and they think it's all going to waste now and they meet in a tavern um in swan's alley off coleman street i don't know where that is but you probably do with all your walks somewhere in the the city anyway. And basically what happens is that they decide to launch an uprising. Very foolish. There's only about 50 of them. They start by going to St. Paul's and they go to a bookshop run by a man called Mr. Johnson. He has the keys to St. Paul's Cathedral and they ask for the keys.
他不给他们钥匙。他们便强行闯入圣保罗大教堂，在里面横冲直撞。有人走过来问：“你们在干什么？”他们问：“你们是哪一边的？你们支持谁？”这个人回答说：“嗯，当然是支持查理国王了。”你知道他们对这个人做了什么吗？他们朝他的心脏开枪。非常残酷。
And he doesn't give them the keys. They break into St. Paul's and they just sort of rampage around. Somebody says to someone comes up and says, what are you up to? And they say, who are you for? Who do you support? This fellow says, well, King Charles, of course. Do you know what they do to him? They shoot him through the heart. Very harsh.
因此，当局不断派遣火枪手去把他们赶走、驱散他们，但第五王权派的宗教狂热如此高涨，以至于他们总能击退那些所谓的民兵连，然后他们通常会
So the authorities keep sending musketeers to sort of dislodge them and drive them off, but the fifth monarchy men are so fired up with religious enthusiasm that they're always beating back the sort of the trained bands, as they're called, and then they usually have,
发起一小波攻击，在城里横冲直撞一番，接着就溜之大吉，躲到城外的一片树林里——他们总是跑到海格特之类的地方，潜伏在树林里。第二天他们又回来搞破坏。这简直就是一连串的混乱，
they'll sort of do a little attack and have a rampage to the city, and then they sort of scuckle off to a wood outside the city, so they're always going to a high gate and stuff, lurking in woods. And then next day they come back and do some more damage. And there's just a series of sort of shambles
最后，在星期三，他们被一些国王的近卫军给合围了。战斗异常惨烈。维纳本人挥舞着一把长戟，在针线街用长戟杀死了三个人。这太惊人了，不是吗？
and then eventually, on the Wednesday, they are sort of rounded up by some king's lifeguards. There's very fierce fighting. Venner himself, he's got a halberd and he kills three men in Threadneedle Street with his halberd. It's amazing, isn't it?
是的，我的意思是，他们基本上就是一群乌合之众。但由于没有人知道他们是谁，而且人们脑子里觉得他们人多势众，所以大家都感到害怕并纷纷逃跑。他们就在那儿横冲直撞。最后，蒙克将军——
Yeah, I mean, they're just an absolute ragtag cult, basically. But because sort of nobody knows who they are, and also people have got it into their heads there's more of them than there are, so people are sort of frightened and run away. And they just sort of rampage about. Eventually, General Monk,
显然就是引发复辟的那个人——设法追捕他们，他们在两家酒馆里进行了最后抵抗：一家是针线街的头盔酒馆，另一家是科尔曼街的蓝锚酒馆，他们被保王党包围了，保王党人强行突入并将他们拖了出来。所以他们当中有很多人被枪决了。
who is obviously the man who had caused the restoration, he manages to pursue them, and they make their last stands in two pubs, the Helmet Tavern on Threadneedle Street and the Blue Anchor on Coleman Street, and they're surrounded by royalists to kind of break through and drag them out and stuff. So a lot of them are shot.
维纳本人，这个制桶匠，被捕了。这可不妙。你可不想被捕。不过，你知道吗？我的意思是，他被判处绞刑、剖腹并分尸。但他显然没有被流放恶魔岛。你宁愿被流放恶魔岛还是被判处绞刑、剖腹并分尸？我其实宁愿被流放恶魔岛。
Venner himself, this Cooper, is captured. That's bad. You don't want to be captured. Well, you know what? I mean, he was hanged, drawn and quartered. But he obviously wasn't sent to Devil's Island. Would you rather be sent to Devil's Island or hanged, drawn and quartered? I'd rather be sent to Devil's Island, actually.
难道你不是吗？对啊。你或许还能得到特赦。也许吧。是的，也许。埃米尔·左拉可能会接你的案子。住进石砌的小木屋，是的。这种事可不会降临到维纳头上。不过……我的意思是，绞刑、剖腹并分尸，这简直就是彻底的阉割。
Wouldn't you? Yeah. You might get a pardon. You might. Yeah, you might. Emile Zola might take up your case. Little stone hut, yeah. That wasn't going to happen to Venner. Although... I mean, a hand-drawn quartering, I mean, that's proper castration.
对，太惨了。太惨了。维纳的下场就是这样。正如作家托拜厄斯·斯莫利特所说，维纳在临终前坚称——他的追随者直到最后仍坚称，如果他们被骗了，那也是上帝本人欺骗了他们。我觉得这真是一个糟糕透顶的借口。
Yeah, it's bad. It's bad. So that's what happens to Venner. And he says, according to the writer Tobias Smollett, Venner at the end affirmed, his followers affirmed to the last that if they had been deceived, the Lord himself was their deceiver. I think that's a terrible excuse, actually.
是的。基本上全都是上帝的错。都是耶稣的错。是的。所以这挺奇怪的，当然，你通常会认为……第五王权派起义最有趣的地方在于，它稍微违背了我们对……
Yes. Basically all God's fault. It's Jesus' fault. Yeah. So it's an odd one because, of course, you normally think... What's interesting I like about the Fifth Monarchy men's uprising is that it slightly offends our sense of...
我们那种略显幼稚的时期划分感。是的。因为我们总觉得16世纪50年代全是疯子、宗教狂热分子和少将。然后查理国王回来了，一切就都变成了——你知道的，跳舞和派对。嗯，这就好比1966年那本《1066和这一切》里的笑话，说沃尔特·雷利被处决是因为他是前朝的遗老。没错。嗯，这就好比1966年那本《1066和这一切》里的笑话，说沃尔特·雷利被处决
our slightly childish sense of periodisation. Yes. Because we sort of think the 1650s is all lunatics and religious maniacs and major generals. Then King Charles comes back and it's all kind of, you know, dancing and parties. Well, it's like the joke in 1066 and all that about Walter Raleigh being executed for having been left over from the previous reign. Exactly. Well, it's like the joke in 1066 and all that about Walter Raleigh being executed
是因为他是前朝的遗老。没错。是的，完全如此。因为他们确实是前朝留下的遗老。但我认为其中有趣的地方在于，很显然，这是一种——这可以说是那种观念的最后回光返照，
for having been left over from the previous reign. Exactly. Yes, exactly. Because they really have been left over from the previous era. But I think the kind of interesting thing about that is that obviously it's a kind of, it's the last gasp of that idea
即宗教狂热是可以付诸行动的，哪怕要付出暴力的代价，我想是的。我的意思是，我想你们经历过戈登暴动，对吧？那是一场可怕的反天主教骚乱的爆发——但是那种由一小群宗教狂热分子坚信自己在替天行道、从而在伦敦街头引发混乱的想法，我的意思是，直到2005年的那两起爆炸案之前，你真的再没见过类似的事情。我想是的。
that religious enthusiasm is something that should be acted on, even at the cost of violence i suppose i mean i suppose you have the gordon riots don't you which is i mean a terrible explosion of right anti-catholic rioting but but that idea of a kind of a small group of religious fanatics convinced that they're doing god's will and bringing mayhem to the streets of london i mean you don't really see anything like that until 2005, the two bombs. I suppose that's true.
而且事实上，这种发生在城市各处的惨剧感，非常类似于巴黎巴塔克兰剧院那个可怕的夜晚。人们不知道发生了什么，谣言四起，人心惶惶。是的，完全如此。为什么这些人要做出这些可怕的事情？我的意思是，那种无法理解其动机的无力感是什么？我也很喜欢这一点，这是自我作为一个青少年学习内战及其后续历史以来一直困惑我的问题：
And actually, this sense of atrocities occurring around the city, it's very like the terrible night in Paris with the Bataclan. And people not knowing what's happening and the rumors and the swirl of it. Yes, exactly. Why are these people doing these terrible things? I mean, what's the kind of inability to comprehend the motivation? And what I also like about this is something that's always puzzled me since I did the sort of civil war in its aftermath as a teenager
所有那些宗教和政治热情都到哪里去了？所以，你知道的，人们曾准备进行大规模的战争、激烈的战役，而在这种情况下，你知道的，还要尝试政变等等。然而短短几十年内，一切就变成了咖啡馆和报纸。公共生活的基调已经发生了改变，失去了激进的能量。我总是想，我很想读一些关于为什么——
is where all that religious and political enthusiasm went. So, you know, people are prepared to fight massive wars, pitch battles, and in this case, you know, attempt coups and all the rest of it. And yet within a couple of decades, it's kind of coffee houses and, you know, newspapers. And something has been – the sort of tone of public life has changed and lost its radical energy. And I always sort of think I'd love to read something about why,
英国是如何将内战抛诸脑后的？我认为那种激进的能量依然存在。我的意思是，我认为异见人士的影响是深远的——这正是他们后来的身份，因为查理强迫每个人都加入英国国教会。而那些不加入的人则被正式标为异见人士。那种异见者的能量绝对是巨大的。但他们并没有拿着长戟到处跑，也没有用枪射击
how is it that Britain was able to put the civil wars behind it? I think that radical energy is there. I mean, I think the impact of dissenters, which is what they become, because Charles obliges everyone to, you know, enter the Church of England. And those who don't are officially marked as dissenters. That dissenting energy is absolutely profound. But they're not running around with halberds and shooting people
别人的心脏，对吧？我的意思是，他们只是在做浸礼会礼拜。他们没有，但他们正在——你知道的，为废除奴隶制做准备，在美国独立战争中发挥关键作用，并开启工业革命。我的意思是，你知道的，那些能量——
through the heart, are they? I mean, they're kind of having Baptist services. They're not, but they're kind of, you know, gearing up to abolish slavery and play a key role in the American War of Independence and launch the Industrial Revolution. And I mean, you know, those energies.
我同意。18世纪初。是的，我同意。相比50年前，英格兰变成了一个更加自满、自我满足、沉静的地方。没错，没错，但那些能量所蕴含的暴力——我的意思是，它们没有转化为某种军事活动，但它们确实——它们对
I agree. Early 18th century. Yeah, I agree. England is a much more complacent, self-satisfied, quiescent place than it was 50 years ago yeah yeah but but but the violence of those energy i mean they they're they're not turned into kind of military activity but they are really i mean they have a really convulsive impact i think on
文化、社会、经济历史产生了真正震撼性的影响。确实如此，但如果把时间快进几代人到沃波尔时代左右，公共生活就会呈现出一种与排斥危机或16世纪50年代完全不同的风貌。确实如此，因为在16世纪50年代，你知道的，都是些做木桶的人，他们觉得自己有权对国家的状态发表意见。我的意思是，这就是改变的地方。它回到了这样的假设：
on the cultural social economic history they do but public public life under let's say i mean if you fast forward a couple of generations to the age of warpole or something public life has a completely different flavor from how it did in the exclusion crisis or in the 1650s or something it does because because the 1650s you know it's it's kind of people who make barrels who feel that they have a right to contribute to what the state of the nation should be. I mean, that's what changes. It goes back to the assumption
只有伟大的贵族才有资格这样做。但在暗流涌动之下，这些人正准备改变世界。嗯，你知道谁对这个很在行吗？本期节目的朋友、大宪章专家特德·瓦伦斯。他有没有顺便报名参加“处教殉道”节目？他将会在
that only great aristocrats should do that. But bubbling underneath, these people are getting ready to change the world. Well, do you know who would be good on this? Friend of the show, Magna Carta expert, Ted Vallance. And is he by any chance signed up to do the execution stroke martyrdom he's going to be coming on to talk about charles the first
新年作客节目，谈论查理一世。这是一个非常令人兴奋的链接。现在展望我们未来准备的所有精彩内容：我们有一集关于1922年的节目，我们有跨越卢比孔河，有查理一世的处决。再往后，在2022年，我们可以期待福克兰群岛战争、鸽子的历史——我想你已经安排好这个了。
in the new year this is a very exciting link for it now throwing forward to all the delights we have in store we have a an episode coming about 1922 we have the crossing of the Rubicon. The execution of Charles I. And further forward, in 2022, we can look forward to the Falklands War, the history of the pigeon. I think you've got that lined up.
美国在海外的圣战，罗马帝国的衰落。我们有各种各样有趣的主题，所以请继续给我们提建议。如果你还没加入，请考虑加入“历史Remainder”俱乐部，
America's holy wars abroad. Fall of the Roman Empire. We've got all kinds of fun subjects so keep your suggestions coming if you haven't already do consider joining up to the Restless History Club
网址是 restlesshistorypod.com，在那里你可以在 Discord 聊天中辱骂汤姆，并要求他进行模仿秀——因为你知道汤姆最喜欢模仿了。我们下期节目再见，汤姆，我们什么时候再和大家见面？我们下周见，我们将探讨1922年——现代社会诞生之年，以及跨越卢比孔河。太棒了，那我们到时候见，拜拜。感谢收听《历史Remainder》，获取加更节目、抢先收听、无广告音频。本集节目还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
at restlesshistorypod.com where you can abuse Tom on the Discord chat and request impersonations because you know Tom loves to do an impersonation and we shall see you when are we seeing them next tom uh we are seeing them next week with 1922 the year that the modern age was born and the crossing of the rubicon splendid we shall see you then bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 restlesshistorypod.com 上，你可以在 Discord 聊天中调侃汤姆，并要求进行模仿，因为你知道汤姆最喜欢模仿了，我们下次什么时候再见呢，汤姆，呃，我们下周将带着《1922：现代社会诞生的年份》与大家见面，还有跨越卢比孔河，太棒了，那我们到时候见，再见，感谢收听《历史的余烬》，获取独家单集、抢先收听和无广告收听 本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。